what's up guys so you guys are probably
familiar with audio splitter cables
essentially what they do is they mirror
what's being inputted into multiple
different audio outputs this is usually
very helpful when you guys are like
trying to listen to music with your
friends or trying to set up like a
multiple speaker setup and stuff like
that but the thing is in the end the
output is sound is the same on each set
of speakers or headphones now this audio
splitter that I'm looking at today is a
very special audio splitter what it does
is it splits the audio signal into left
and right so now if you guys are trying
to set up like a surround system but
there's only like a few audio outputs on
your PC but you have multiple different
speakers that use your left and right
speakers then this is very useful what
you can do is you can plug your left
speaker into the audio splitter where it
goes onto the website and just plug the
right side if your right
kidding so now what would happen is now
there's a different audio being
outputted from each of your speakers and
this will be very helpful for when
you're setting up ground sound systems
where ever it in multiple different
speakers so let's see how this
Kable performs let's jump right in
okay guys it's really easy to set up
this little cable you just plug it the
cable in to one of your audio outputs in
your PC and then the red goes with the
right speaker and the black goes to the
left speaker once you got that there's
no setup required when you just play
music automatically the right lane will
go into the right speaker and left label
or that left speaker that's as simple as
that
so I have this nice triple monitor set
up with three monitors that each have
their own respective speakers now the
problem for me is that on the back of my
PC there's an output for the center come
on a monitor but there's no separate
output for left and right but there is a
stereo output so when I'm using this
cable for ease and plugging the cable
into the steer output and I'm using left
left are the black output and plugging
that into the left monitor and you need
readout quit plugging that into my right
up monitor now by doing that but I am
able to accomplish this my press love
speak right here it comes out the left
side where is the center speaker it
comes out of the center it's the same
with the right side
[Music]
this helps me avoid setting it to mono
audio and gives me some variation and
sound being outputted here take a look
at what it accomplishes
[Music]
[Laughter]
as you guys can see doing this gives
more righteous sound and gives it more
in-depth sound fall this cable allows
the user to set up a surround such
system on the cheap you don't have to
buy really expensive gear anything like
that you fight a fight on cable and do
some speakers they have lying around
being able to create a cheap surround
sound system okay guys I hope you guys
enjoy that quick overview of that audio
splitter cable and if you guys are
interested in what monitoring I'm using
make sure to check out my volcano view
link down in the description below
that's all for now guys
if you guys like this video and how it
was helpful make sure give me a like if
you guys loved it and like see more
videos just like this make sure to
subscribe that's all for now guys